[Music]  we used to be a family of two now look  at us here we are yeah it's pretty big  out there and I'm sure your head must be  filled with questions  now then let's see welcome to Planet  Earth  there is much to see and do here so  let's get started with a quick tour  life on Earth is a wonderful thing it  looks big but there are lots of us on  here we may all look different but don't  be fooled we are all people and we all  share the earth  the world is so huge that no matter how  much I learn don't never be enough it  sounds like you feel washed if you're  feeling lost just start with watching  [Music]  there is so much more for you to learn  about Planet Earth  make sure you look after it as it's  we've got  for the first time in his life he  speechless